مستخدمه منصه تويتر سيتمكنون من معرفه ما
اذا كانت حساباتهم تتعرضوا للحجم والاخفاء
دون علمهم وايضا كيفيه التعامل مع هكذا
موقف
هذا ما اعلن عنه رئيس شركه تويتر
الملياردير الامريكي ايلون ماسك الميزه
الجديده وحسبت تصريحات ماسك تشرح سبب حجب
حسابات بعض المستخدمين صعوبه العثور على
صفحه الشخص في خانه البحث منشورات
المستخدم غير مرئيه لمستخدم تويتر
والمتابعين هذا الاعلان وان كان ليس غريبا
على الى الماسك المثير للجدل الا انه اثار
سجالات وعزاؤه البعض الى الجدل الذي
احاطته وتر في عقاب تقرير حديث اصدره
موقعه ادلتيكس المتخصصه في امن المعلومات
قال فيه ان تويتر يمكنه الوصول الى بيانات
مستخدم اكثر من حين الف موقع الكتروني
التقرير اشار الى ان من بين هذه المواقع
التي يستطيع تويتر الحصول على بيانات
مستخدميها مواقع تابعه للحكومه الامريكيه
واخرى لشركات الرعايه الصحيه حيث بامكان
تويتر الحصول على البيانات عبر اداه
الاعلان الخاصه به التي تسمى بكسل والتي
يضمنها المعلنون في مواقعهم لتتبع وتحليل
واستهداف المستخدمين منصه تويتر تستعد
ايضا بدءا من الثانيه عشر من ديسمبر
لزياده اسعار الاشتراك لخدمتها المدفوعه
تويتر بلو على تطبيق اجهزه ابل ما يعني
تحميل المستخدم تكلفه الحصه التي تقطعها
ابل من المدفوعات بسعر 11$ في حين سيتم
تخفيض السعر الى ثمانيه دولارات اذا تم
الاشتراك بها عبر موقع الويب ابل ستور ومع
كولاري ماسك في اصدار اعلاناته الا انه لم
ينسى التهديد بمقادتي عدد قليل من موظفي
تويتر الذين يواصلون تسريب معلومات سريه
لوسائل الاعلام وفق تقارير جاسم محسن
العربيه